el primer lugar a dónde va nuestra
comida para la digestión en el cuerpo es
por supuesto la boca y la boca en
realidad tiene un par de nombres por
extraño que parezca por supuesto la
llamamos boca más comúnmente pero
también se le conoce como cavidad oral o
incluso cavidad bucal entonces
aprendamos un poco más sobre lo que pasa
en la boca y echemos un vistazo el
objetivo general de la boca es tomar la
comida y convertirla en algo llamado
bolo un bolo es una esfera de comida más
fácil para digerir ahora hacemos esto en
dos pasos principales lo primero que
hacemos es masticar nuestra comida y eso
es algo con lo que estamos muy
familiarizados hay un término científico
muy elegante para masticar y es
masticación y hay dos cosas en nuestra
boca que nos permiten masticar primero
por supuesto son nuestros dientes y
hablaremos ampliamente sobre ellos en
otro vídeo y la segunda es nuestra
lengua la lengua como sabes se encuentra
justo aquí y también tiene un nombre
elegante que sería importa
conocer se llama link hula eso será útil
en un momento la lengua está formada por
dos tipos de músculos hay músculos
extrínsecos que se encuentran fuera de
la lengua y se anclan a ella y también
hay músculos intrínsecos estos músculos
intrínsecos son aquellos que sólo se
encuentran dentro del cuerpo de la
lengua sólo se encuentran aquí los
músculos extrínsecos nos permiten hacer
cosas como elevar la punta de nuestra
lengua y lo contrario deprimir o bajar
la punta de nuestra lengua nos permiten
sacar la lengua de nuestra boca y
también nos permiten retraer la de nuevo
hacia la boca por otro lado los músculos
intrínsecos dado que sólo se encuentran
dentro del cuerpo de la lengua cambiarán
el tamaño de la lengua cuando se contrae
así que hay tipos de músculos que pueden
acortar y ensanchar tu lengua y estos
son los que corren desde la punta de la
lengua hasta la parte posterior de la
boca y entonces diremos que corren de la
parte anterior a la parte posterior p
y también hay músculos en tu lengua que
le permiten alargarse y estrechar
y estrecharse porque estamos sacando la
lengua y estos son los que corren desde
tu lado derecho al lado izquierdo de la
boca o de lado a lado de modo que
escribiremos de derecha a izquierda por
aquí muy bien increíble así que después
de que hemos logrado la masticación cuál
es el siguiente paso bueno el siguiente
paso es la descomposición de las
partículas de comida por hidrólisis y la
hidrólisis como recordarán es un proceso
en el que las enzimas descomponen las
macromoléculas ahora las enzimas que
causan la hidrólisis en nuestra boca
provienen de las glándulas y hay muchas
glándulas en nuestra boca y hablaremos
sobre ellas cada una de ellas aporta un
cierto componente de nuestra saliva de
la que hablaremos aquí y hacen cosas
diferentes entonces primero nuestras
glándulas pueden liberar principalmente
contenido zeros o contenido ser oso
significa que es rico en enzimas enzimas
y sales muy bien entonces nos
enfocaremos en las enzimas el otro tipo
de contenido que nuestras glándulas
pueden liberar son bocinas
las músicas que se componen
principalmente de musina y el objetivo
de la música es humedecer la comida para
que sea más fácil envolver en un bolo y
enviarlo a la parte de atrás de nuestra
boca para tragarlo las enzimas por otro
lado aclarar esto aquí cortarán la
comida la descompondrán por hidrólisis
de modo que la primera glándula que
mencionaré es la glándula más grande que
tenemos se llaman glándulas parótidas y
se sitúan en el costado de la boca justo
encima de la mandíbula y liberan
alrededor del 25 por ciento de lo que
hay en la saliva y debido a que son
verdes son principalmente 0 sos entonces
contienen enzimas en un momento
hablaremos de cuál es el siguiente tipo
de glándula que tenemos parece un
trabalenguas son las submandibular es
las glándulas submandibular es y éstas
liberan alrededor del 70% de la saliva y
se encuentran como su nombre lo indica
debajo de la mandíbula que es el hueso
del maxilar y éstas también son
principalmente ceros as aunque también
liberan algunas cosas mussi cosas
siguiente glándula que tenemos se llama
glándula sublingual y tal como su nombre
lo indica se sitúa justo debajo de
nuestra lengua nuestra link hula término
que acabamos de aprender y representa
aproximadamente el cinco por ciento de
nuestra saliva y como sugiere el color
libera principalmente musina libera
alguna encima pero en menor cantidad que
las bocinas y finalmente la última
glándula que tenemos que contribuye a la
hidrólisis en nuestra boca se llama
glándula de von berner la glándula de
bonn hérner libera menos del 5 por
ciento de nuestro contenido salival muy
poco se encuentra principalmente en la
punta de nuestra lengua y lo que tiene
de especial la glándula debón hérner es
que libera una enzima llamada lipasa
lingual lipasa lingual que como su
nombre indica descompone los lípidos o
más específicamente los triglicéridos y
esos triglicéridos se descomponen en
ácidos grasos libres como diglicerido o
mono glitz heridos así que sólo
escribiré mg y mc para big liz heridos y
mono glitz heridos
y eso es lo que hace von berner por eso
es única
las otras tres hasta cierto punto
liberan una enzima que se llama alfa
amilasa que es una enzima que toma
carbohidratos como el almidón que es un
gran trozo de carbohidratos y lo
descompone en carbohidratos más pequeños
entonces solo escribir aquí
carbohidratos más pequeños de modo que
romperá el almidón en carbohidratos más
pequeños para ayudar con la digestión y
cuando digo digestión debo aclarar que
la cantidad de hidrólisis o el alcance
de la descomposición que tenemos por
parte de estas enzimas y del corte de
alimentos es muy insuficiente para la
absorción de nutrientes la única razón
por la que tenemos digestión por enzimas
en la boca es por el gusto cuando
descomponemos el almidón y los lípidos
eso nos ayuda a apreciar realmente
algunas de las grasas de una hamburguesa
o algo del azúcar en los refrescos sin
embargo el problema es cuando tenemos
demasiada azúcar en nuestra boca porque
a la boca le gusta estar en un ph de
aproximadamente 7.0 en eu tral pero
cuando tenemos mucho azúcar como
hay grupos hidroxilo que se establecen
en las moléculas de glucosa los grupos
hidroxilo pueden ser ácidos y si bajamos
el ph hasta algo menor de 5.5 podemos
comenzar a desmineralizada o romper los
dientes debido a la naturaleza ácida de
la boca tendré esto en cuenta la próxima
vez que quiera tomar un refresco